State
um with Alex talking about
experimental and observational studies
in the presence of stochastic
thank you uh all of you for braving the
the rain and for getting your shoes
waxed uh hopefully by the end of the
talk my shoes will recover and be the
correct color
um I want to thank Ben and Alex for uh
organizing this has been really really
good
um you might be confused by why a
statisticians here and uh right Nicole
and they call it others yes
um
the you might be confused why
statistician is here it's mainly because
I want to learn uh about some of the
things that have been uh talked about
today and I think some of the work that
we're doing sort of jives nicely with
the work that has been presented so far
um so the talk today will be a little
bit different than uh what we've seen
the last two days but I I think that
there's some nice symbiosis that we can
um I'll learn from each other so sort of
the big picture uh that the world that I
live in is we have complex problems that
we're interested in studying these are
causal problems we want to run
experiments and it turns out that
running an experiment is no longer
feasible just by you know flipping a
coin and doing an A B test that doesn't
give you the answer that you want
because there's this weird uh complex
social behavior that's happening behind
the scenes and it might be tainting what
you think you're learning about
and so there's a ton of literature uh
that's been coming out over the last 15
years in statistics and causal inference
and econ and CS dealing with Notions of
interference uh the fact that my
treatment might affect my friends
outcomes homophily the fact that my
friends might behave similarly to me
contagion the fact that things happen
over time and sort of lots of other
different problems that networks bring
along
and uh one of the sort of guiding
principles of this literature has been
that there exists a static Network where
we're interested in doing sort of a
static experiment and the first part of
the talk will give you an example of how
you might go about doing the type of
experimentation but the reality is that
everything is stochastic in our world
and we have lots of sort of reasons to
worry about the fact that networks might
change and so your interference might
stochastically change or contagion might
stochastically change and how do you
deal with that is sort of interesting
um sort of the the way that I've thought
about doing experimentation has been in
this context of model assisted design
where I postulate a model for the
universe not unlike many of the sort of
simplified models that people uh work
with and I try to come up with an
experiment that will perform well uh
without actually regard for the model
when I'm doing the estimation afterwards
and I'll sort of make that clear in a
little bit the problem is that when you
have Dynamic networks Things become hard
and so how do you incorporate these
Dynamic Network models into the uh the
model system design is sort of the next
stage or the next phase of this universe
and what do you do in observational
studies that's sort of a whole other
problem
all right so I'll give you two
motivating examples this is stuff that
I've worked on uh
I think we can all agree that uh people
infect people but in fact actually one
person infects one other person it's not
sort of a collective action
um but when you're studying whether or
not masking works or vaccines work you
need to account for sort of all of the
interactions and you can't see here in
Gray but there are connections between
these people and these are real people
in a real college campus and they were
interacting with each other and then the
flu happened and some of these people
were instructed to stay in their room uh
if they had symptoms some of these
people were not instructed to stay in
their room and we wanted to see whether
or not that type of isolation was useful
and the thing is without accounting for
the fact that their Network ties uh it's
kind of meaningless to think about this
intervention because the whole point of
the intervention is cutting Network ties
so how do you do that you have to
account for the network process that's
under
uh in a different Universe I think a lot
about political polarization
and uh the this idea sort of comes out
of the fact that over the last 20 30
years we or 40 or 50 years we've sort of
become very familiar with the idea that
Americans are just divided on pretty
much everything
and what's interesting is that unlike in
the
um you know 60s 70s when uh actual
socioeconomic or demographic principles
were predictive of uh policy positions
now partisan idea is substantially more
predictive of of position and so we're
interested in understanding whether or
not there's something to blame for this
so there's been a hypothesis that Echo
Chambers are to blame that we just sort
of self-isolate and that we don't expose
ourselves to opposing views and so the
follow-up hypothesis to that over the
last decade has been maybe social media
well so how do you test whether or not
social media is to blame you are
necessarily dealing with some kind of
network process this is a picture from
an experiment that we ran on Twitter and
our goal was actually to collect
unconnected individuals we went to a
survey firm that promised us this is a
representative IID sample from uh the
United States we can discuss sort of
later whether or not anything is a
representative IID sample of anything
but we were not expecting these people
to be connected on Twitter and as you
can see they were definitely connected
if we were to have ignored this portion
we could have introduced massive bias
into any kind of
um
uh study that sort of is interested in
understanding whether or not selective
exposure is doing something are you
going to talk more about this or uh I I
wasn't planning on it this is sort of
just as a motivator but I I'm sure
it's more likely to be a rejection of
the null hypothesis that they were
sampling correctly or is there a
reasonable process for Twitter linkage
that would actually have produced this
I
I probably don't really want to
speculate on camera too much about what
is going on behind the scenes of these
large survey firms but I will I will
hypothesize that one of the reasons
these people might be connected is
because they're participants in a
service
and in fact
uh I mean I'll give you three seconds
more on this so these are clearly
colored by partisan ID uh the middle of
the blue uh one is some kind of
journalist and I don't know why they're
responding to surveys but good for them
and the middle of one of these red ones
is somebody whose Twitter handle would
not be able to put up due to you know
problems
uh so uh yeah I think that there's
something striving about but yeah
so uh this this talk is probably too
long and I'm gonna try to De jargon it
as much as possible but sort of the
first half is this idea that we want to
do high quality causal inference we want
to design experiments uh that's part of
something that we control uh sort of how
we randomize people into a or b into
test a treatment or control and then the
second half is going to be how do you
leverage stochastic modeling to really
improve some of these experimentations
what I hope to get out of the stock so
this is for you this is for me I want to
sort of understand how these things
connect with the literature that has
been described uh really nicely the last
couple of days and uh the other thing
that I want I'm going to have one slide
on at the end uh we have a nice
experimentation platform that we've been
developing at the polarization lab that
I think based on my understanding of the
last couple of days is something that
could be very useful to validate some of
these very interesting sort of
equilibrium results that people have
been presenting
so uh we hope people will be able to use
it very very shortly
all right
uh there's too many collaborators to
name uh these are sort of only people
that were directly on the papers that
I'll sort of bring up but uh there's a
lot of other people in the polarization
lab and some more fantastic students
um fan booze on the market this year
everybody should hire her uh Faye will
be on the market in a couple of years
um yeah all right so
uh this is probably one of the first
times that I um presented causal
inference at a workshop where I don't
think I think I'm the first one to talk
about causal inference so I'll give sort
of a a quick background on what it is I
think of when I talk about causal
inference I think of it in the potential
outcomes framework there exists sort of
different universes and individuals
might be assigned to some kind of
treatment and we'll think about
treatments as binary zero one
and uh a potential outcome for a unit is
indexed by all of the treatments of
everybody else and so that means that
there exists two to the end possible
different types of universes uh that any
one individual could experience clearly
that's really really hard to work with
uh we can't really do much with that and
so we make lots of simplifying
assumptions and so the standard
assumptions for the first 80 years of
causal inference has been some version
of an individualistic treatment response
or sutva or uh whatever we want to call
it
um and essentially it says only my
treatment affects my outcome and so
suddenly you went through it from a two
to the end space to just a two space
which is nice
once you do that you can start thinking
well what is it that I actually want to
learn about and people frequently want
to learn about average effects so this
is the average over the individuals in
the sample or in the population that you
care about and it's the difference
between their two things but obviously
the curse of causal inference is that
you only observe one of the two
universes right you either observe
somebody's treatment response or their
control response and so much of the work
has been sort of spent on explaining why
estimators like this are good
and it's probably fairly clear you don't
need to have a background in causal
inference to really understand why this
is good this is probably going to be a
consistent estimator of the average for
the treatment people right if everybody
is IID sample from a population if
randomization happened everything is
good then this will be a good estimate
similarly for this for the control if we
sort of Leverage two things right we
leverage the fact that we can either
randomize or that we might learn the
selection mechanism and use this
networks make this necessarily more
difficult because suddenly
this might not be a viable assumption
and you are sort of uh going to have
issues with whether or not your
randomization is inducing some kind of
interference or whether or not inducing
hemophily or it's being manipulated by
the homophily and so on and in
observational settings it's like way way
worse you have to make way stronger
assumptions or you need to have way more
data
but we want to do causal inference on
networks because we are interested in
studying disease prevalence Social
Development uh business transactions and
so on and so we need to sort of deal
with this so homophily interference are
sort of things that people have been
thinking about there's this third thing
that I won't have time to talk about but
it's this idea that you can't actually
give treatment to only one agent you
have to give treatments to multiple
agents simultaneously turns out that
makes things way way worse
um that's for future problems but we
have a nice paper about with Panos tulis
and eduardi um
so we can't make this a simplifying
assumption that Z1 through ZN are
somehow not going to affect oh sorry uh
homophily statistically uh so homophily
here would mean that y i uh my my
outcomes are correlated with your
outcomes if we're friends
[Music]
so it's some kind of correlation I
haven't put any model on anything yet
I'm just sort of uh yeah so Monopoly is
birds of a feather tweets together right
similar people behave similarly
interferences I give you treatment we're
friends and so I get some kind of
outcome change because of that
all right so we can't make a simplifying
assumption and the other thing that's no
longer clear is what are we actually
trying to learn from these experiments
before average treatment effects were
kind of meaningful conditional average
treatment effects is something that has
been sort of the All the Rage or
heterogeneous effects or individualistic
effects but what can you actually learn
when you have a network because you
suddenly need to contrast things that
sort of are in two to the end type of
space which is not obvious so a very
popular effect is this total Network
effect or the global average treatment
effect which contrasts everybody treated
versus nobody treated
we will stood in sort of the effect of
isolation or the value of isolation
these Direct effects does the vaccine
protect me actually
uh indirect effects or sort of the the
social influence or the pure facts
literature has been interested in what
happens when my friends are treated and
I just sort of exist in a vacuum
and the sort of the combination of these
two is some kind of herd immunity or
total notify
and the problem with
this universe versus the naive a B test
universe is that I'm going to make the
argument that you need to make a
decision on what you want to learn
before you can run the experiment and
once you've run the experiment it's
extremely unlikely you'll be have access
to all of these estimates
because some experiments are just unable
to give you access to more than one
so uh what we want to estimate we might
be able to control we might be able to
control how we randomize the individuals
into treatment and we have a control of
how do we want to Samurai summarize the
data the estimator
and uh sort of on on the side of doing
honest causal inference we should fix as
much of this as possible a priori and so
the estimate presumably needs to be
fixed we need to know what we're
studying before we run an experiment I'm
going to claim we should probably fix an
estimator before we run the experiment
as well so that we don't P hack our way
to an answer and so then the only thing
we get to sort of play with is this
randomization scheme can we design a
better experiment by uh changing how we
randomize people into treatment control
so
um there's early work uh in the causal
inference literature uh and I realized
that I did not update these slides with
all of the relevant mansky references
mansky has similar papers in the 90s and
2000s as well uh and and so this
universe considered two-stage
randomizations where you had separate
groups there's interference within group
there's no interference across groups
turns out you can run an experiment and
study lots of stuff that way
this really nice uh work by ugander at
all has uh is sort of the first time
that people really carefully as far as I
can tell work towards an experiment
that's actually motivated by the
quantity they're interested in studying
uh in the network section the universe
and they were interested in total
Network effects and they showed that
this notion of graph cluster
randomization works really really well
so you take a giant graph you construct
small microcosms of your graph in there
by doing some kind of cost smart
clustering and then you treat each of
these as a representative subgraph and
then turns out that gives you access to
Total Network effects
it also is very clear from that setting
that it will not give you access to
direct defense
because you no longer have people who
are treated who don't have any treated
neighbors around them right because
you've now treated whole neighborhoods
so you can run this experiment but you
won't be able to learn anything other
than this
we're going to be interested in Direct
effects and we're going to make a
simplifying assumption that interference
and homophily are going to be restricted
to the neighborhood of a node this is
just for ease of exposition this can be
done sort of uh in a more generality
later
um this is a notation heavy slide I just
want to sort of set up set the stage we
have 2N agents or nodes in our graph uh
it's I'm gonna have to divide by two
later so that's why there's two n of
them
um d uh n is the neighborhood D is the
size of the neighborhood
um and these are sort of
quantities that exist that describe the
universe for this individual so there's
some kind of direct treatment effect for
a participant right so this is the truth
that would have happened had they been
treated and nobody else around them is
treated there's some kind of function
that summarizes how the treatments of
their friends affects their outcome
and then maybe there's some kind of uh
Baseline effect or covariate effect
and if you have t is the set of treated
units this is the type of model that's
going to motivate our work so this is a
very simple model it essentially
postulates that everything is additive
but what's important is that at no point
we're going to try to estimate the model
itself this is just going to be how
we're going to the universe under which
we're going to evaluate a very naive
simple estimator that doesn't know
anything about the model
yeah so just think about that as
Baseline effects for a person so this is
the fact that you just might be
different from me in Baseline yeah
function there's a function of the
subsets that's very general right to me
that means that I don't just care about
a number of effective defeated neighbors
but also combinations that's right yeah
so this is
uh because it might be the case that uh
some kind of interference is not just
based on how many friends you have that
perceive treatment it might be great
because of the fraction of Frontier C
treatment that's sort of a simple
version of that but it could be much
more General right this is much more
General that's right uh it could be the
so
we we have even further extensions of
this where it's even more General maybe
because you have friends who are also
friends with each other that's more
powerful interference than if they're
not connected to each other right so
that's sort of leveraging some
literature for sociology so it
I assure you we will have to simplify
this a little bit in order to actually
get the theoretical results we want but
uh sort of currently it's very general
at least understand it a little bit so
the simplifying assumption there is that
the actual effect is coming from the
treatment of my neighbors and not their
actual outcomes yeah yeah so this is so
what kind of applications are ones where
the treatment is what affects my outcome
yeah that's that's a good question and
sort of this there's a little bit of
confounding between Notions of
interference and contagion uh and it's
usually analyzed sort of simultaneously
uh you can think about get out the vote
type of
um uh
experiments where it's the sticker that
you voted I don't care if you actually
vote it it's the fact I gave you a
sticker you showed me this sticker so
that's not the actual outcome it's the I
allowed you to show this step
what's these the experiment will be
testing the effectiveness of stickers
yeah yeah the effectiveness of the badge
that your friends voted did that make
you vote
um but I agree with you that this is
sort of one of the reasons why it's
important to move towards a more
stochastic version of these and a lot of
the analysis that
sort of those previous literatures have
been doing is exactly the setting where
things are static and and that might be
insufficient realism
[Music]
okay so our goal is going to be
estimating sort of the average over this
population of these teens right but we
don't have access to the F's we
um we just have a way of controlling uh
who gets treated and who doesn't
and the other thing and this might be
sort of
um uh uh deviating a little bit from our
universe we're interested in the naive
estimate this is a difference in means
estimator it's the same one that we had
on the first slide
and the reason we're interested in this
estimator is because it's really easy to
explain
example with stickers so you're saying
that like if I get a vote
like you want to test the probability
that I then I'm gonna vote if you
already gave me the sticker yeah no so
that's that's a bad example for for the
direct effect because they were
interested in pure effects so direct
effect might be
um I you know I advertised to you about
um a particular
um you know I give out flyers and I'm
interested in whether or not you did
what you saw in that flyer versus if
you're doing something because your
friends got the Flyers
you can make the time frame and everyone
else exact would be likely to be because
of the purchase that like that's right
that's right
countries like why do you have
restricted to the averages as opposed to
something like Universal medicine
schools
so why am I why am I getting
so uh the first thing is the question
sort of is why is this a set of like an
ipw or something more sophisticated this
is easier to explain
um when I
when you open the New York Times and
somebody and you read the outcomes of an
experiment uh this is more likely to be
explainable
the other issue is that well the other
thing is that we're doing sort of an
experiment so we hopefully don't need to
inversuade by anything
and the last thing and that's sort of my
own sub box inverse relating blows up
variants you can obviously correct for
that doing some kind of Hayek thing but
nonetheless you're gonna end up with
something that might be unstable
especially in this network but there's
still something a little bit I mean you
would think I suppose I would have
thought statisticians would say do
anything and then you would worry about
all the things that you've said you
should worry about rather than just say
we're going to focus on this one one
thing
well so if I fix this then I can tell
you how this estimator behaves under a
different randomization space so it's
true that I could
not fix this and try to study I could
try to overfit to this model but I don't
want to do that right so I want to I
want to study how does this estimator
behave under this type of universe
Senate already but why is the average
treatment protective
if you ignore the editor yeah so it's
sort of this value of so this is the
average direct effect right and it's
it's the value of isolation so you could
be interested in Imagine you have some
kind of vaccine that there's some kind
of zoonotic disease you want to go and
vaccinate people in a place where
they're not likely it doesn't matter if
their friends are vaccinated or not
because they live on a remote eye
so I'm interested in does the vaccine
prevent zoonosis
these are very good questions and and
what's interesting and important here is
that uh I think that the universe that
we live in is somewhat limiting because
once they construct this randomization
scheme you're not going to be able to
learn about pure facts because I'm going
to get rid of the pure Effects by Design
and so uh one of the things that a few
students and I've been working on is how
do you design experiments that are
flexible enough to give you access to
more than just like one thing and it
turns out to be really hard
um this this is sort of just motivating
this type of linear model uh this is too
much notation but essentially this
linear model corresponds to some
decomposition of potential outcomes so
this is in fact the causal quantity it
defines causal quantities and you can
think about sort of this TV as this type
of direct effect and so on I'm having to
go back to this slide uh later but uh
this is sort of just justifying if we're
not making stuff
all right and so this is our operational
quantities so we're interested in this
direct average direct effect we're going
to use this estimator the best estimator
we could hope to use is this one that
actually knows things about Baseline
characteristics
and that knows exactly how much uh
interference there is obviously we don't
have access to the interference but the
difference between this estimator and
this estimator is telling us something
about how high quality this estimator is
right so if we can bound C it's the same
as bounding the error in our estimation
depending on what f is
we're going to try to uh bound the first
and second bonus
yeah so it's it's ideal because it knows
kind of a lot right so it's for
everybody in treatment it knows it is
essentially decomposed uh the outcome
the whys into the parts of it that are
the direct effect and the interference
effect and so it's essentially thinking
about
for treated people I do y of V minus
their interference and for the control
people I do y of B minus the
interference
so it's ideal because it's it's sort of
the Oracle that knows about the
interference
all right and so what's in my opinion
really cool in this in this result is
that it's a really easy design so
remember I have two endnotes I'm gonna
suggest that you partition them into
pairs however you want
you're going to assign one member of
each node to treatment and one to
control
under some sort of simple lipsticks
assumptions on the interference so again
we're very general still which may or
may not be useful but it turns out to be
sort of exactly the type of lipsticks
assumption that is used in the
literature when people actually fit
models so uh linear interference is
gamma d-lipshits fractional
interferences gamma Lipschitz and so on
so it's not a it's an assumption that if
I didn't have to I wouldn't make but
it's also exactly what people fit when
they fit models without regard for the
actual uh design of the experiment
and what's really really cool is that
I can bound the bias in the estimator
um
so this is these are the Lipschitz
constants
and this is a sum so the bias of the
estimator of the naive estimator is
bounded above by a sum not over the full
graph not over everybody who's connected
but over people who are connected who
also happen to be in my partitions so
they're paired together in the partition
and then it this is sort of standard
stuff that comes out of many much
network analysis
but
and B really really encouraging because
it means you can design a completely
unbiased experiment under this
extraordinarily uh complex interfere
potential interference
you can just pick your partition so that
it is not uh doesn't include any edges
in your graph
and then suddenly you're unboxed now
maybe that's sort of not enough for us
uh and so that's what where we're going
next but in reality this is very
powerful if you're Facebooking you're
running one billion of these experiments
and for some reason you care about
Direct effects instead of uh uh total
effects just do this and suddenly you
are guaranteed and unbiased
um this bottom sort of just there's a
recovery of existing results it says
that if you randomize over part pick you
this partition uniformly at random you
get this type of bias which is exactly
what's uh what people have been doing in
the literature
okay so are all partitions made equal
and I'm going to claim that they are not
so again remember our goal is to remove
the interference effect
and so let's imagine that uh this is a
particular type of randomization we have
two treated individuals and two control
individuals it's a very simple graph
and you can see that in this graph each
treated individual has a treated friend
and a control friend and each control
individual has a treated friend and a
control friend and so if interference
only depends on the number or the
fraction of treated and controlled
friends I have
then definitely if I were to look at the
difference between the treated and
control individuals here the untreated
individuals I will cancel out the
interference patterns right because the
interference patterns are identical on
the other hand here it feels innocuous
right all I did is I said treat two and
three instead of one and two in the same
exact graph but it's very clear now that
this one is not good because all of my
treated people have only controlled
neighborhoods and all of my control
people have treated Neighbors and so I
wouldn't cancel out the interference
pattern so it turns out that some
patterns are some some partitions are
better than others right some types of
treatments are better than those so can
we do this in general can we sort of
figure out what is a good we are calling
them quasi-colorange uh versus a bad one
so uh so
sorry let's let's imagine for a second
that they're very very similar that they
only depend on the number of treated
versus the number of control frames
that's that's sort of a simplifying
assumption but
but even if they're not as long as they
are definitely depend on those patterns
very similarly then that would be enough
so we have some of the specification
results as well that say that you can be
a little bit off and it will still do
pretty well
all right so uh to your point let's
let's make it simpler and so our
interference now just depends on the
number of treated friends and the number
of control friends that's or the
fraction
and what turns out to be the case is
that we can control the variance or the
mean squared error of our estimate
it's really nice and it has these three
parts
and what's great about these three parts
is that they're all things we can
control and we can choose randomizations
in order to get this these numbers to be
really small
so uh the first part depends only on our
partition and it depends on the
differences in the degrees between
people you've paired up
so this is because at the end of the day
we only care about now treated degree
and control degree it turns out that if
you pair up people who have similar
degree treat one of them and don't treat
the other you're going to do better
that's good
this third part is again very similar to
that original bias result right it's
telling us that we only care about
individuals that contribute to this mean
squared error by in terms of individuals
who are share an edge and who are in my
partition set so make sure to pick
partition sets that don't have any
individuals who share an edge in the
graph
and so it turns out that we can choose
this better partition this way by
ordering people according to their
degree and just pairing them up this way
this will control the first term and
that's the dominant term essentially
and we can do even so this already gives
us that means squared error goes to zero
that we get consistency of this
estimator everything it's nice uh but we
can do even better by then after doing
that doing a little bit of shuffling and
paying maybe a little bit on that first
term by getting a huge gain on that last
third term and that's sort of a simple
optimization result that we could sort
of play around with and it seems to
improve things a little bit
um
I'll show you just a a couple
it seems here that basically you're
getting one over n variance which is
right so yeah so you're so what are
these type K's and yeah it's got to be
in there right so yeah so these K's are
uh new lipsticks constants they tell you
so K1 tells you a little bit about how
uh important it is to have different
number of uh traded friends and K2 tells
you uh how how important did it how much
of a change in your interference there
is if the fraction of treated friends is
good and so these are just control these
are slightly more complicated controls
that look like
actually those I mean
this is sort of where you need to start
getting into domain expertise but you
can imagine that it might matter for uh
for you that three of your friends got
treated and not anymore and so that's
sufficient for you then that gives us a
dollar
okay
thank you
yeah we need the minimum degree too
demon is the minimum
so yeah we have results on sparse
networks where this sort of still works
it needs it needs to grow at least a
little bit it's a slightly different
result it's just a little bit more math
but uh even so you get a slightly
different
perhaps it's going to go to Infinity
anyway right and so in sparse graphs the
result is a little bit different uh you
still need yeah but but it's that you
can still get it to work it's it's only
some yeah D minus constantly
Instagram
all right uh it's a little bit of a of a
bake off uh that I
guess I'm gonna happen
Okay let's skip the video uh under my
specification we still do well that's
fine
uh what I wanted to get to is
um
is these slides and there's another one
sort of afterwards with that I'm not
going to get to but
um I want to think about how do I
leverage the stuff that I've been
learning the last couple of days on this
and essentially one of the things that's
missing in there is any kind of decision
making by these agents right we're not
actually taking into account but some
people might
sort of to your point choose to share
things or choose not to share things how
they end up uh doing things and so that
I think is is sort of an important place
where we can start uh thinking about
that and we can design better
experiments by thinking about the
Strategic behavior of individuals uh and
I I've gained some insight into sort of
how to start incorporating
the last Point here is that we care
about Dynamic networks as well and I'm
not going to be able to actually go
through the next 10 or so slides of how
do you study Dynamic networks but uh let
me just sort of give one let me go back
to this slide so if you remember we
might have an experiment that's running
that some people were told to uh do one
thing versus other people were told to
do another thing and that uh that
treatment might change the way in which
they interact with the network and so
what's particularly interesting in the
model that we've set up and this is
Joint work with Jason Shu who's been
here for the semester in famboo and
Alice in a yellow uh is thinking about
a network so this AIG jft is the uh is a
binary indicator of a connection between
two individuals at time T changing as a
function for example of disease steps
so here we're postulating that maybe
people connect and disconnect from
people in this network as a function of
whether or not those people are sick so
if I'm sick you might disconnect from me
and when I become healthy again you
might reconnect with me
and turns out you can sort of
incorporate this into the stochastic
epidemic models really Naturally by
introducing sort of new uh competing
poisson processes and sort of thinking
about this as this complex continuous
time Markov chain
um we do this sort of in a Bayesian
framework it's hard because there's a
lot of missing data and what's really
nice about the work that we've done I
think is we both have an exact sampler
in some settings and then we have a
really uh sort of efficient stochastic
cam to do things that are even harder
um
but
I
some of these people might have
individual characteristics as well and
that is sort of where I think that a lot
of the work that
um we've been listening to the last
couple of days can really be leveraged
in order to think about
it sort of actually strategic Behavior
by individuals I might disconnect from
you not just in terms because you know I
I have a coin toss with a particular
probability but I might disconnect from
you because I've been looking for an
excuse to get rid of you right or I
might not disconnect from you because
your family and I don't care that you're
sick I'm going to help you out anyway
and so that's not captured in our model
right now but it's clearly a very
important thing and uh sort of in new
work with David McAdams we're thinking
about how do you incorporate that in
order to study sort of these uh
efficient behaviors of individuals
um I'm sorry that I'm skipping through a
bunch of slides that these show details
of the model uh and I'm happy to talk
about them uh later on uh in our sort of
Baseline setting we studied this
particular group of 100 students we have
information about all of their
interactions over 10 weeks at five
minute intervals right they all were
given cell phones and uh the cell phones
were pinging when they were in the same
room together for uh or sorry in the
same in the vicinity of each other and
so we have pretty good information about
how they interacted we also have daily
information about flu infections and we
haven't weekly information about
recoveries and also a lot of sort of
both stochastic sorry both Dynamic and
static uh attributes of these
individuals and what we're able to learn
for example in the setting is that
individuals for optional hand washers
are less likely to get sick so that's
that's kind of nice so wash your hands
this is flu-like illness this is sort of
a fairly generous definition of
infection because uh yeah but yeah
but why did I tell you all of this it's
because I think these models are way
more realistic than the first one that
we talked about right and and uh I I
think we need to be able to incorporate
this into the experimental design uh
sort of to leverage these types of much
more flexible models
um and uh what's nice is that these
models give us access to forward
simulation and this forward simulation
allows us to think about things like
this so here are some epidemic curves
under different strategies of uh strict
quarantine for all strict quarantine for
some symptomatic people or other types
of quarantines that you can introduce
and what's important is that it's not
just a single curve these are stochastic
curves that are generated and so you can
see that under strict quarantine you
could do really really well right and
squash the infection immediately but you
could also be stuck in in the same limbo
as as you would have been and so this
variability in this is potentially very
important when you're designing a policy
and this this is sort of uh uh an
important step in the direction of
better policy though
um but
um
what what sort of the goal here is to
now start incorporating
um agent behavior in into the actual
modeling framework and to sort of
understand whether or not some of these
agents are behaving you know myopically
or they're behaving uh or they're trying
to maximize something right uh there
could be some kind of cost of being
infected but there might be benefit to
having that link because you might get a
job out of it or something and so how do
you incorporate that into
um
I'll conclude I have two or three two
more minutes uh sort of about this
platform that we've been thinking about
uh how do we where can we actually run
experiments so the first experiment that
we had we had a campus full of students
it's a closed essentially population we
had I I'm saying we I didn't actually
collect the data this was collected
before my time but uh
probably couldn't run that experiment
now but at the time it was doable it was
about 10 years ago
uh the second experiment was run on
Twitter and it was really really hard
for us because we needed to collect a
ton of information about these people we
weren't working with Twitter and so we
needed to interact with individuals on
Twitter but without actually having
control over their uh their feeds and so
we didn't really know what they were
seeing we told them to turn off this
turn off that but who knows what they
actually did
and so what we've been developing and
it's nearly done and I I'm happy to say
that it's nearly done it's sort of an
experimentation platform
and this this features of this platform
allow us to generate social media feeds
and currently it looks more like Twitter
than it does like Instagram but those
are sort of just think features that are
down in the pipeline uh and you can
designate how individuals are required
to interact with the social media
environment you can measure engagement
information flows and other options
and So based on the talks the last
couple of days I think that certain
things can be measured here so for
example you can measure value of
virality by sort of essentially running
the type of experiment that you were
describing Kevin uh you can uh think
about sort of effective connection Types
on the information flow so in this
platform the idea is that individuals on
board and it looks like Twitter to them
or it looks like you know Tick Tock
where it looks like something and
they're told to engage with it in some
way I'll show you some screenshots of
what it's going to look like
um you can measure Notions of
persuasiveness because you can have them
engage with each other or you can have
them engage with gpt3 Bots and that sort
of is a nice sort of universe to work
with and then uh you can measure sort of
whether or not some types of information
or quantity or uh or a quantification of
interactions are more meaningful than
others
so this is a a previous version of this
platform that we built that we ran some
experiments on and individuals here were
just sort of uh uh on this platform they
have to have conversations but the new
platform looks more like this
and you as the researcher have complete
control over everything that goes on
this platform you can choose what kind
of like buttons or dislike buttons to
have you can choose whether or not you
display some kind of decomposition of
them based on partisanship or based on
status you choose what kind of
um uh what kind of content is pre-loaded
or written by the bots in the background
so you can have high quality content and
low quality content uh
one of the things we're working on is
sort of understanding how these Bots
will actually perform in in real life uh
I don't know if everybody saw
yesterday's chat gpt3 that uh
there's some evangelists and some people
who have attempted it and doesn't really
work I think Ben did you tweet about not
working yeah uh but uh sort of we get we
get to sort of control a lot of stuff
and we can decide the type of
participants sort of these Bots or you
can have Confederates running in there
and you can control sort of all these
things and I hope that people do people
generate content here yeah so the way
that we're gonna get so the first round
of of experiments we're planning on
running is people are going to be
onboarded they're going to be a bunch of
bots in the background that are writing
their own content and the people are
going to be asked to generate their own
content they're going to be asked this
is a universe that you live in now
please behave like you behave in your
regular universe
uh things we're interested in are sort
of whether or not user Choice induces uh
better Behavior whether or not uh
translating uh sort of from uh polarized
content to less polarized content and
improves interactions and so
but I think lots of the things that have
been described sort of in a in a model
framework are testable on platforms like
this
so thank you very much this is just some
references and uh I'm happy to take
questions
as the switch is happening if somebody
has a good question
is yeah
[Music]
yeah so that's a good question so that's
the stochastic modeling part uh gives us
a realistic model for the universe that
allows us to do
the reason I'm interested in it is
because it allows us to then uh think
about what kind of concentrating
response functions are reasonable in
order to design future experiments so
essentially you can you can use the
outputs of these models in order to uh
design what previously was just
partitions this is probably something
else where I would know the potential
app from the constant on a particular
types
it might yeah that that's sort of the
goal
uh it's easier said than done I can
probably implement it but I can't we're
working on that
um
just in time so she's still getting back
up but thank you very much um so next
another 45 minutes
of
garage presenting too much data prices
and inefficiencies in the data markets
take it away you have until 10 50.
thanks very much for your invite uh so
I'm going to talk about too much data
prices and inefficiencies in data market
this is a joint work with
zaggler and Annie McNamee who is in the
audience